[Musik]
ist die gänge mir natürlich wgs und
reisen sitze den ganzen tag nur zu hause
oder hier aber warum du bist du hast
zeit warum fährst du nicht wegmacht
immer eine reise
das ist alles so kompliziert
darin bringt man den laptop her war es
wie so weil wir zusammen ist ein ausflug
stopp moment das hört sich gut an
angebot für senioren gruppen eine
zugfahrt durch das rheintal nach bingen
am rhein mit mittagessen und
stadtrundgang
so fährt der zug am hauptbahnhof in köln
und war die abfahrt ist um 9 uhr 45 von
gleich sieben was kostet das hin- und
rückfahrt kosten 50 euro und du musst
nicht umsteigen
du kommst um viertel vor zwölf in bingen
am rhein an und um halb sieben abends
wieder zurück
toll aber alles an einem tag und das mit
zu anstrengend du kannst auch im wege
übernachten wir finden bestimmten
hotelzimmer für dich das buch
ja okay das war's jetzt drücken wir die
verbindung nach außen suchen auch noch
ein hotelzimmer raus
43 ich bin schon ganz aufgeregt
[Gelächter]